good afternoon uh thank you for your
patience uh waiting uh patiently as we
made our way up here my name is eddie
mandry director for africa and the
middle east at yale university
and your excellency honourable ministers
permanent secretaries mukawa ambassador
pillay
members of the delegation ladies and
gentlemen
i extend the heart valve university
welcome
today
we're absolutely delighted to have you
join us
for this african leaders forum
lecture each year on the sidelines of
the united nations general assembly
we have uh an a meeting or convening of
heads of state at yale
so that they can deliver some kind of
vision
for their nation and the transformation
and development of the economies
this will be the seventh such lecture at
yale
and first following the start of the
covet 19 pandemic
this lecture is presented as part of the
yale africa initiative a university-wide
effort launched by president salovey
at his inauguration in 2013 aimed at
refocusing our engagements across africa
elevating discourse on africa at yale
attracting some of the best and
brightest students from across the
continent
among them current botswana's cabinet
member uh vince lina
and
one other critical dimension of the
initiative
is our efforts to foster bi-directional
collaboration in areas of mutual
interest with partners across the
continent president marcisi's visit to
yale is particularly significant because
moments ago his excellency signed a
memorandum of understanding between yale
and the government of botswana for a new
partnership that will serve as a launch
pad for mutually beneficial exchanges
and cooperation between both sides on
research and training focused on various
aspects of natural resource management
his excellency mokwesi marsisi will
speak on his vision for transitioning
botswana to a knowledge-based economy
his lecture will be followed by q a
moderated q a conversation here with me
and an opportunity for him to respond to
questions from some of you in the
audience please mute your mobile devices
and before his excellency comes up it's
my pleasure to invite to the podium a
member of our own community a phd
candidate at yale school of in the
environment who has spent a fair amount
of time in botswana working with her
counterparts at local ngos and the
okavango research institute at the
university of botswana she's passionate
about the nexus between livestock and
wildlife
and how humans livestock and wildlife
impact each other
most recently she worked in the botti
west sub-district in botswana
focused on the interactions between the
central kalahari game reserve and the
makagadigadi
national park i hope i got that right
close close
caggy orrick i welcome you to the stage
[Applause]
mela moto
[Applause]
oh thank you very honored to be
welcoming
his excellency to to yale um
his excellency president maquitsu masisi
began his career in the education sector
from 1989 to 2004 he had a variety of
positions in public sector including
national coordinator for social uh
social studies education in botswana
education officer in the united nations
and hiv and aids prevention researcher
with the tropical disease research
center
in the 2000s politics came knocking and
he heeded the call
in 2009 he successfully contested the
election to serve as a member of
parliament for mushupa
subsequently he held various cabinet
level appointments from public
administration to education and skills
development
in 2014 he was endorsed as the vice
president of botswana and was given
responsibility overseeing national
programs spanning from poverty
eradication
economic diversification and job
creation
in july of 2015 president massi became
the chairperson of the ruling botswana
democratic party and retained that post
through 2017. in 2018 president masisi
was elected as the fifth president of
botswana
in the october of 2019 president messici
was reappointed and as for a five-year
term after the botswana democratic party
won the general elections by garnering
the majority in the national assembly
president mississippi holds a masters of
science on in social studies education
and instructional systems design from
florida state university and a graduate
degree in economics and social and
social policy from manchester university
where he was a distinguished achievement
scholar
it is my absolute distinct pleasure and
honor to be welcoming his excellency
president maquitsuma sisi to the podium
to deliver his yale african leaders
forum lecture entitled botswana's vision
for a knowledge-based economy
thank you
okay
thank you very much
professor peter
salve
in
absentia president of yale university
distinguished members of the faculty
the director for africa
initiative
the rio community
my distinguished
fellow mozwana from bhutiti west
honourable minister kwape
and senior government officials from
botswana ladies and gentlemen a very
good evening
it is a distinct honor
for me to have been invited to this
occasion
to address you on an important subject
regarding botswana's
perspective
on a knowledge-based economy
this honor
does not only extend to myself
but it also extends
to botswana
the people of botswana
my acceptance of the invitation from the
yale community
is a living testament
to the special relationship
that has been established and continues
to flourish
between the republic of botswana and
yale university
i suppose a living testimony of the yale
africa initiative
yale university and its
living commitment
to excellence
remains a source of inspiration to all
of us
who hold similar dreams to a path
to a sustainable and prosperous future
i have no doubt
that the seeds of collaboration
that we have already sown
will fully blossom
for the mutual benefit of our friendship
it is in this regard
that i wish to share with you
where botswana is headed
as we march towards
a knowledge-based economy
such an ambitious and noble initiative
is also an invitation
to the yale community
to join us
and help us
in this journey
at the independence of botswana in 1966
botswana was one of the poorest
countries in the world
despite a small population
subsistence agriculture was the main
source of livelihood
for the people of botswana the botswana
there were some observers
who even questioned the state of our
mind
for taking the bold step of seeking
independence
however
with innate determination
our forefathers were not detained
from going ahead with the project
the country depended heavily on foreign
aid
for both its recurrent
and development budget
however botswana's economic fortunes
changed
in the early 1970s
following the discovery of diamonds
which became the mainstay
of our economy
to this day
our founding fathers who managed our
resources
with a high degree of frugality
invested heavily in the construction
of schools
roads
hospitals
airports as well as a provision
of basic social services
which has taken the form of free
and affordable education
amongst others to enhance a better
standard of living
botswana's natural resources have also
been
in the form of
our natural endowments namely mineral
deposits
flora and fauna
the land and the people
the primary focus in regard to these has
been the people
as the owners beneficiaries and the
driving force
behind the exploitation
of such
resources
the country graduated to
high middle income
but as the economy grew
the population
multiplied at a faster pace than
economic development
even though we have invested a lot in
human capital
the productive capacity has decreased
and we need to retool and to reskill
our people in order to make them
relevant to the dictates of the global
market
in our national vision
we have set ourselves amongst others the
target
of being a high income country by the
year 2036.
the vision further enjoins us to strive
to become a knowledge-based economy
distinguished guests
knowledge and technology
are the heart of economic development
for any country
a knowledge economy as we may all be
aware
is largely driven by three main factors
being human capital
relevant and effective policies
and the requisite information
and communication technology
infrastructure
essentially a knowledge economy is
realized when most income and economic
activity
is driven by content and knowledge
rather than other physical resources
at best
such content and knowledge should be
domestically contrived
and
patented
as a country we have prioritized in our
current
national development plan
for policies
that will drive economic development
towards attainment of sustainable
economic development
these are
promotion of export-led growth
ensuring more efficient government
spending and financing
building human capital and the provision
of appropriate infrastructure
the total sector has for a long time
accounted for the majority of botswana's
services
though others
exit such
exists such as financial services
administration and other
business services information technology
services and a range of professional
services
many of these require knowledge based
one of these require knowledge
specialized skills and for us as a
country we need to support their
development by strengthening the
intellectual property framework
ladies and gentlemen getting the
educational basics right
is a prerequisite for equipping botswana
with the skills to successfully
transition
to a knowledge-based economy
educating our people and sustaining
productive human capital
has always been at the core of our
economic development
since independence
some of the more specialized skills
that we need to create and manage
the fourth industrial revolution
for ir technologies such as coding
genetics
data science and analytics
will in due course
need to be central to school
and college curricula
this is why this financial year the
government has committed about 24
percent
of the overall national budget to
education
this translates to 15 billion
730 million pula or about 1 billion
573 u.s dollars
making it the largest share
in our national budget
the proposed budget will cater for the
for the development
and sourcing of e-content for schools
training teachers
and school managers in basic ict skills
and the use of technology on teaching
and learning
the allocation is geared towards
providing appropriate education
and training
to students
so that upon completion of their studies
they could become active players in the
transition
of the country to a knowledge-based
economy
this will include improving the
foundations
of learning and the quality of our
education and extending the scope of
pre-primary education
at the secondary level
there will be a focus on improving
outcomes for learners in terms of maths
and science
areas where botswana's performance has
been below expectations
furthermore
the speed of change in technology and
production
obligates that learning be a lifelong
process
and that today's learners will need to
have the capacity to re-equip themselves
with skills perhaps several times during
their working lifetimes
hence the importance of softer skills
such as flexibility and initiative
this will be important not just for
individuals but also for the economy as
a whole
one of the challenges of the 4ir
is that emerging technologies such as
automation
artificial intelligence genetic
engineering and blockchain may displace
jobs
as production becomes more technology
intensive and capital intensive
distinguished guests in view of the
global trends towards
a knowledge economy
we have embarked on an ambitious project
to broaden the national digital
ecosystem
through the national digital
transformation strategy
commonly known as smart bots
to deliver a smart sustainable society
for our country
the strategy
aims to transform the public sector to
efficiently provide services to citizens
and businesses
the smart spot strategy also seeks to
increase mobile network and mobile
broadband coverage and
to provide internet connectivity to
government facilities
and strategic locations across the
country have been identified for
connection to ensure the most
impact as reflected in my government's
reset agenda
which has prioritized five areas in our
development trajectory
digitization has been identified as one
of the priority areas that has the
immense potential to unlock and enable
high productivity among our people the
majority of whom
our youth
trade and knowledge based services
require upgraded connectivity with high
quality dependable
low cost bandwidth
stimulated through the widespread
rollers of e-government services
and ensuring effective operation of the
national ict backbone and local area
networks
to this end part of the second largest
share of our development budget
will cater for information communication
technology projects
being the government data network
upgrading national backbone networks
government data center and local access
network
my government continues to look for
strategic development partners
who can assist the country to capitalize
on their fourth industrial revolution
technologies to advance our objective of
connecting our people for the betterment
of their lives
i want to highlight the fact that
botswana subscribes
to an open market economy and
government's role is only facilitative
in nature
therefore
i want to assure you that we remain
committed to governance
that facilitates a private sector as an
engine
of economic growth
the creator of wealth and the much
needed employment opportunities for our
people
this
in a nutshell
is a synopsis of our vision
for a transformative process
towards a knowledge-based economy
i will once again
enjoin the yale community and other
william partners to accompany us
on the promising journey
i thank you for your attention
[Applause]
right
thank you very much mr president for
really engaging lecture
centered around your vision for a
knowledge-based economy in botswana
i'd like to begin with a small anecdote
i heard that
you earlier had an engagement with
bloomberg and
1965 there was a film
there's a book published by ian fleming
now widely read and even adapted to a
movie in 1971 james bond
filmed by the same names diamonds are
forever mr president rumor has it you
were in new york in the possession of
the world's third largest
third largest diamond
one found earlier this year one thousand
one hundred and seventy five carrots at
a mine in caraway botswana is this true
and if so can you officially put the
debate to rest are diamonds forever
you know
thanks to the question
let me begin with the facts
has the diamond been discovered that's
the third largest in the world
true
was it discovered
at the karue mine at karue mine owned by
lukara a diamond a canadian company
true
was it in potato west
true
is it about 1175
carrots
true
is it rough
true
is it a diamond
it's a diamond
were we in possession of it this morning
or holding it don't you
true
do we own it no
[Laughter]
it is owned by lucara and i'm really
proud to introduce
somebody who is very closely associated
with it
one of the world's leading lights in the
diamond trade and industry
and technology
management or dead
welcome
[Applause]
from hb antwerp he's one of the partners
with lucara who are going to be
managing that diamond yes
and
doing what they think is best to
give it additional value
and what are we waiting for is
government we want them to succeed the
most
get the most money out of it
because then we just get some tax
[Laughter]
we get royalty yeah
and we urge them
to go out and find more because they're
going underground
all right well you have and yes diamonds
are forever okay well you have settled
the debate then well thank you for
outlining kind of all the dimensions of
this karaoke diamond that was founded i
mean so we convened in an interesting
time of unprecedented
uh disruption in our global community
the pandemic has caused a lot of pain
anguish death loss of life
and economic struggle across the world
how are the people of botswana doing and
how are you faring
you know the the coveted 19 pandemic has
been
devastating it has had a deleterious
effect on our economy
on our livelihoods and and people
um
but we are resilient people
and so we've got to face up to it
and confront it
and the best confrontation when you're a
third world developing country without
the power of the by by chemical or by
medical
response
is to use people power
and
use your intellect to manage it
on the basis of the advice we get from
scientists
and i'm glad this country um
though arrival university has given us
some of the best brains to do that
um who is here with us today professor
music
trained in harvard oh he's our deputy
coordinator
for kavit 19 an infectious disease
specialist
and so they advise us and what to do
and we follow that advice and we
regulate on that advice
we communicate on advice he's on
national tv every week he's a household
name
and he basically dispenses this advice
in language that people understand
and can relate to
and he practices medicine
and and teaches
young doctors at the university
teaching hospital
and so we we have responded in ways that
we can the best but it's affected us
we've had a loss of life
with lots of jobs
lots of opportunity lots of market
and we've seen our
our our you know bank balances
and government accounts depleted
as we buy the necessary ppe and other
um
interventions such as vaccines
even though we paid so many vaccines
that have not yet arrived right
thank you for outlining that and uh
we also would like to note that uh we do
welcome
people who've been to the university up
north that won't be named as part of our
community not much crimson around but
that's okay
but we appreciate how difficult and
challenging this time must be for you
and the people of botswana and we hope
that
as vaccines become more accessible that
there is some light at the end of the
tunnel um
many leaders some leaders who have come
to speak at yale in the past have
sometimes
pointed to
the miracle of singapore
lee kuan yew's model of transformation
and development as being
one of the
pathways they aspire to taking to
transform our continent
i'm curious about your sentiments on
several african countries steering to
look eastwards
to partners
and for opportunities for trade and
commerce
technology transfer and so on
china obviously comes to mind as well so
i'd be curious about your international
engagement strategy and your engagement
in the
well
east
broadly speaking we have a very open
foreign policy
we are not aligned
uh because it's in our best interest not
to be aligned it's in our best interest
not to be dealing with problems that are
not going to help us develop
and so what's honest foreign policy is
premised
on
protecting and growing botswana's
interests first
we have friends
both in the east and the west
from whom we derive a lot of benefit
we exchange views and we share values
but we do have differences
and those differences we manage
diplomatically but those things
essential for our development
and growth
we negotiate for and we take
what's best for us at the time
and both have a lot to offer
so we're in the lucky position of
shopping
and
making you compete
and we pick what we think is the most
competitive
we're not always right
and so we learn from those experiences
so we do shop in the west
we've shopped in the west much more than
we shopped in the east
but we also do shop in the east
for both ideas and content
um and so um
it's it's suffice to see that
we do
work very harmoniously
with china very harmoniously with the
united states
and others as for the model of
development
yes singapore has
done exceedingly well
but you know singapore is not botswana
and botswana is in singapore
for one the land mass is different
the weather patterns are different
we in botswana have a big budget
that is dedicated to a wildlife
department
something singapore could never have
right in botswana we we have to deal
with human wildlife conflict
and a lot of the human wildlife conflict
these days is to do with elephants
we happen to be the
home of the
highest number of elephants in the wild
in the world
we've looked after them on your behalf
right
and when i say your behalf i mean the
world humanity yes it is it's a resource
that we will all share
but you know we do get into conflict
with them and we've got to manage that
conflict
without
endangering the people without
endangering the wildlife
and so it's not exactly
transferable
a model
as one would wish
we are a democratic system an open
you know liberal democratic system we've
had elections every five years and my
it's my favorite hope and
determination at least while i'm in
charge that they
we will have elections every five years
free open transparent and fair elections
and it is the winner who will
assume power
so if we go to the elections and i lose
i lose
i go home
and i won't turn back i won't want to
come back
and so
you you can't exactly impose
a model from a city nation state
on a a a developing state uh like
botswana
thank you thank you for kind of pointing
out is the fact that the context is very
different and it's important
and there are various nuances that are
unique
to your nation and various needs and
dynamics
that
make it necessary for a policy that's
responsive to those needs
um i would like to open to a few
questions from the audience i know we
started a little bit late so please
raise your hand and press the button
when the light turns green you'll be
able to speak into the microphone kindly
introduce yourself and
keep it brief because we don't have much
time thank you
great
with the transition to the knowledge
economy for botswana what is the
botswanian government doing to encourage
entrepreneurship among botswanans
one more question
gentlemen at the back in the gray suit
the great jacket yep
uh thank you your excellency uh james
wang i'm a yale world fellow over here
um
you you mentioned uh the role that
botswana is playing as a steward and
indeed many countries on on the condor
playing as a steward of the co of the
world's natural biodiversity and bounty
coming after the covet discussions we'll
be heading into cop 26 and the
discussion around climate
what is your view on what is the
how is botswana thinking about its
positioning around cop26 and what do you
think is africa's overall role in the
fight against climate change globally
all right um
thank you very much
what's up sonic i've been doing to
encourage uh entrepreneurship botswana
we're providing a lot of
education and opportunity legislative
space
is created
so that there are some reservations
we tussle back and forth about
the
um
prudence of
uh
um
reservations
and and the lack of it so we're very
careful in in its use
but when we have infant industries
develop and we have a nice and
entrepreneurial culture emerge
we attempt to protect that
we provide training we provide
mentorship
we provide procurement
categories for certain
things to be bought
from
those entrepreneurs
but it's just never enough
it's never enough because
we need such
small scale entrepreneurs to grow and
get to the next stage
until they become fully fledged business
persons
um so it's a it's an ongoing
uh challenge
uh and we do provide training right up
to university
um it's it's the relevance of that would
which is important
um james wenge
you asked if
botona being a steward of our national
natural resources
um what are we thinking about
the upcoming
environmental conference in november in
edinburgh is it
glasgow glasgow sorry in scotland
um
[Music]
you know we are
we're very um we're signatories the
paris
accord
one we are
very determined to make sure that we
play our part
in
contributing to the management of
climate change
we're extremely
worried by nation states
whose impact
is significant
with respect to
issues of climate change
delighted that america
is back as a party to the paris
agreement
but you need to catch up you need to
make up for the last time
you really need to because
you're such a big economy and a big
player
we need to harness the
green
energy space
and we may be just as guilty because we
apparently have some of the best sun
opportunity
and we have a integrated resource plan
that we've approved
and we're tilting
to go green
we say this and we want this
in a situation where we had discovered
huge deposits of coal
i mean more than 200 billion tons my
goodness
can you imagine
and so
we're tustling
and grappling with
what we do with all that
there were others who were wanting to
exploit it
um but increasingly as you know
um the financial institutions would not
be willing to fund that beyond 2030.
and so if anything started now it really
would make a return on investment
so so we are deeply committed
we want other countries in africa at
least those we associate with in the
natural management national economy
management space
to go together with us on that but it
needs huge investment and a lot of
investment is r d
and so we look to learning leading
researchers you know institutions
such as yale
to help us at least with a capacitation
to be able to help ourselves in on that
well uh i don't envy you having to deal
with that decision about the cold
deposits but last i checked
diamonds come from carbon and coal so
this could bode well for the future of
botswana in some way
we'll take a few more questions uh one
here this gentleman
another hand back there
the orange shirt
next yes my name is desmond
and i have a question
regarding
transboundary relationship between
botswana and her neighbors
and how
you intend on your approach
towards ensuring that this initiative
that you're undertaking
uh is also
transient and it moves into these other
your counterparts and that you become
an influential point
where all the other
countries can look around you and begin
to copy
what you're doing is there initiative to
do that or are you just focusing more on
the protectionist and just
one it's all for this country
yes
thank you your excellency my name is
abraham keita and i'm from liberia a
student in your college
uh first of all i wanted to say thank
you to the people of botswana for being
uh the shining city on a hill for
prioritizing democracy in africa you
know
my question has to do with
what is your government doing to promote
women empowerment and women involvement
in democratic processes oh yes we
celebrate uh botswana for having uh
sustained decades of democratic rule
we had seriously karma and uh
uh
katana massiri and all the full
presidents before you but what is the
government doing to ensure that women
are inclusive in the governing process
of botswana thank you
yes one more please all right
hi my name is abby culka i'm from the
school of public health um thank you so
much for coming to speak to us today
and i wanted to ask what does
cooperation look like within the
continent for you for and for botswana
under this length lens of
knowledge-based economy
again please oh what does cooperation
look like on this con on the continent
of africa under this lens of
knowledge-based economy
take one more one more yeah let's do it
my name is
from
nigeria so i was
i'm really curious to know uh
just like the last person said botswana
is one of the shining lights
on democracy
uh in the continent but if you look at
current reports freedom house uh
economic intelligence
the decline of democracy in the
continent is really worrying
increasingly a lot of countries in
africa are going from
democracy to hybrid democracy and you
know plain dictatorships
and the african union
has one of his commitments the
protection of democracy in the continent
and
serious resistance to undemocratic
change of power i just wanted to know
the
the council of the head of states what
are you guys doing at this point
to address this decline
and what lessons
can we pick from botswana what has
worked in botswana that's not working in
the other parts of africa that we're
having this
you know terrible terrible loss to
democracy we have about three four
queues in the continent
between last year and this year so what
was your take on this thank you
thank you so much um
let me begin with their
where did we stop now was it ibrahim
keita
were you the first one
no no no desmos one desmond i think it
was desmond right yes uh but any
neighbors yes um
how are we
influencing one another
um
we we are part of uh a region
uh both in the economic space through
the
saku
the oldest customs union in the world
began in 1910
that's between botswana
lesotho namibia and south africa
and so we we cooperate
it's not a a a
an equitable
system
uh as many unions are not
uh and so we're trying very hard to to
make it work better as we we all develop
we're also part of sadek
that's a socio-economic and political
organization
and it's got
you know a bigger number of
member states
where in we also have a very political
and focused
organ
which i just happily
uh chaired for a year and i hand over to
president omaposa the organ and politics
defense and security cooperation
it is that instrument
more than any other within sadek that is
used to influence
one another
in the political space
you know uh between uh between countries
in the spirit of promoting political
cooperation promoting defense
cooperation security cooperation
um
and
a battery of values
for holding elections for instance is
generated a system of monitoring for
elections is generated a system of
presidential influencing
is it and i could just let you know i
wish i had my phone yeah to get out um i
was
messaging
up in between ourselves and president
lungu
as the elections were unfolding
and part of that messaging was to
to ask him hey
you know
let's let's be with it i mean it's it's
you know
you you you look doesn't look like you
made it so
please accept the results
um
it's not easy to say that to another
head of state because
we often
are
restricted by the considerations of
sovereignty
um but we we as as colleagues
you'll find out when you're president
you know
[Laughter]
you talk to one another sometimes very
frankly
particularly when you when you develop a
friendship
and so we've developed that within sadek
and
it doesn't always work
all right i must admit it doesn't always
work
because you can only do and say things
to a point
and it's only when it gets really bad
that you you would raise alarm
there's also the um and this is a
continental-wide one it gets to part of
what udo i think is asking
it gets a little more complicated when
it gets to the african union and bigger
many of the african countries including
those in the south
attained the independence through
struggle
right they fought for liberation
and when you're a liberation hero
that
seems to cling on and
seems to blind
some people into
not
seeing on pointing out not accepting
some things that may be going wrong that
may be
happening
and there's a lot of solidarity
uh that
you know
has been part of the narrative for a
very long time
but that's slowly changing
with the generations
that come on
but you know outright you know um
uh condemnation and
uh is often uh
viewed very negatively and not effective
it's best to engage
um
you know
as as countries
relate so yes i would accept what you
say udo
um
you know democracy
it would seem is on the decline
um and it's very worrying
um
there are a number of coups that have
taken place there was a time when the eu
um
abhorred coups
but
we still do
but they still
do happen
um so
there's a lot more that i think needs to
be done
in terms of
capacitating and training
those who would manage their affairs in
africa there's not enough of it
being done
ibrahim keita
we thank you for you thank us for
democracy in africa but what are we
doing in busan to promote women
empowerment
in in politics
gosh i wish the women would answer that
because
we do everything we can to try and
encourage them
and i speak on behalf of even the
opposition the political parties in
botswana
we do very badly
many women have said very openly they
find politics in botswana unattractive
it's vicious and nasty
and so
there's also the the aspect of cost
over time
men have
had great opportunity
to generate income more than women
generally but what we have done as a
government at the executive level is
promoted a lot of women
probably 50 percent of my permanent
secretaries are women
at least all the permanent secretaries
from the parent secretary to the
president the deputy foreign secretary
the president
and all the permanent secretaries in the
presidency three ministries of the
presidency in botswana are women
and one of them is here permission from
ministry of international affairs
they're women
but you can have a conversation with
their why
she doesn't skip over and contest the
election
and and
and others that's my chief of protocol
it's a woman deputy parent secretary
level you want to raise your hand
[Applause]
you can ask her why they don't get into
politics but
we've had some very successful women
politicians
there are very few
the ruling party has the most
number of women in parliament and the
only women in parliament from the rural
party the other parties and
unfortunately
well i shouldn't say unfortunately
we don't want them to increase the
numbers so much
don't have any in in parliament
so we we will continue to
you know
encourage
our women folk at the political party
level
there are a number of models because
we're going to be reviewing our
constitution
that some people are postulating
perhaps having a reservation system some
people don't like it at all
you know our culture system some don't
like it at all but it's not really for
me to say
the nation will speak and they will
decide what they want to do
because it's disturbing when you have
more than 50 of your population
not represented
at the leadership level it's very
worrying
it's almost like a single parent-headed
household and the parents are men
you know when they go beer drinking it's
a problem
abe coke i think it is
what does cooperation look like in a
knowledge-based economy
particularly the region
um
we have a
training exchanges intellectual capacity
exchanges
you know we have our lawyers patent
lawyers
uh we we could be
offering training in one university in
the region
and uh sharing that with others
that is be the basis for the treaty so
it's really about building the ecology
for that
and our customs clearing systems
our payment systems and platforms
so there's a lot of work to be done in
terms of providing solutions
and new systems
of exchange
um
and that's where the excitement is
because you know you can generate so
many things that do not occur
that just are not there
and you can develop a new economy
um so i look to our young people to
really
you know take us to the moon
uh on this so
and we will pay pay them to to help us
do that
i think those are the ones that were
asked
yes yes no i think that's uh
unfortunately we might have just time
for one more question and then we wrap
up so uh this is a tough one wow
okay uh gentlemen right here
uh
hello my oh
my name is nadeem uh thank you very much
uh for coming and and for the great
lecture
um
my question is
with respect to energy and energy
access with
particular regard to rural communities
in botswana
um
as you talk about a knowledge-based
economy
uh increased technology access
education
these things seem inherently tied to
energy access and reliable energy access
and i'm wondering what your
administration is doing
and perhaps who you're partnering with
to improve energy access in the country
to enable
the knowledge-based economy that you
speak of to take root
thank you
it's a great question
great question
a
we're looking for more partners
right
but we're looking for partners that are
creative and innovative and you know why
because some of the places that do not
have energy or access to energy
are in far
remote
difficult to reach
lowly populated places
but with this enormity of sunlight
we think
the solution will be solar
off grid
we have our integrated resource plan
and by the way you know access to energy
and reliable energy is quite high in
botswana now
a rural electrification is pretty high
but the rate at which you know
settlements are growing
some sometimes outstrips
the supply capacity within a particular
locality
um but with the integrated resource plan
it would allow for those who generate
energy
excess energy from a solar plant to sell
it
to the grid
and the beautiful thing in southern
africa is that we have an integrated
exchange system for selling energy to
other countries
so you can actually trade and sell your
energy to zambia to mozambique and
so to wherever there is a deficit
um and we plan in in uh to be
um be able to export energy within the
next three years
because we floated tenders to
you know generate
100 megawatts of
energy from solar additional
to what we have
and we will
be
licensing independent power producers
as they come and go um a rooftop solar
you know systems are coming up
and so
you know any other new partners who come
with new solutions
come see us
we're a great country to be in by the
way i mean just
we love visitors we
take good care of you
we let you in and out we let your money
in and out as you want
[Laughter]
you know
in any currency
no exchange controls
um and if you have excess money you can
just go down the street and
and buy some diamonds and take them home
excellent
well i
am certain that there will be many in
this room and outside this room who will
take you up on your invitation
to build stronger cooperation and ties
between
us and the people of botswana especially
in your ambition to develop a
knowledge-based economy you've covered a
lot of ground in your lecture and
conversation today
gender equity climate change renewable
energy
natural resource management adding
you know value in the supply chain for
people education
but also importantly the
your vision for a non-aligned approach
to your international engagement to
fulfill the priorities and needs of the
people of botswana through cooperation
and so it is in that spirit that we're
delighted to have you here on our campus
to set the stage and articulate that
vision
so we're out of time for the
lecture portion of the session of this
session
but
we would ask you that you please remain
seated as
we exit and there will be a following
reception upstairs but before you leave
mr president there's the obligatory
uh yeah
that you need to put on
initiation or a picture
i'm not sure gentlemen at the back will
be too happy with this but
there we go
all right
excellent
she likes the elbow she does
excellent that's right today yes
right this way thank you thank you very
much thank you
[Music]
you